dick i don't know if you remember but i
interviewed you while we were hanging
off the cn tower last year while i was
talking to you about
stranger things three you remember yeah
that's why i said nice to see you
i was uh i actually have i have those
photos in the hallway here in this
big cupboard of stuff uh from that so
i i definitely do remember thank you for
for taking me on that wild journey
okay here's the thing i was freaking out
carrie elwes was freaking out and you
were very calm
cool and collected very similar to your
character nick in this movie so are you
kind of like nick in real life
i think so i think i think there's
obviously some
similarities that's obviously the
touchstones i used in sort of the
character development here
because i always try and find the
similarities before i find the
differences in the characters i play
um but yeah i mean there was definitely
we were talking before with
a different journalist about uh the
dancer karaoke scene
and like that's definitely that's
definitely i'm
very uh shy uh and i don't have a huge
amount of self-confidence when it comes
to
to to song and dance so that was quite a
lot of me coming through let's just say
that was probably the
the biggest uh commonality between me
oh very nice well you and geraldine had
just such fantastic chemistry in this
movie what was it like working with her
it's great so it's fantastic to work
with another australian she's absolutely
lovely
um and just has a lot of connection i
think she she offers really
great insight into like this emotional
landscape of
of love i think and she makes
you feel like she's really interested in
you and she wants to hear what you have
to say
and um you know for anyone like it as an
emotional
sort of tactic let's call it it's um it
definitely works especially
under this subject matter um why were
you so excited to be a part of this
project in particular
it's such a big 180 from stranger things
um you know from that character in that
world and i think
i wanted to explore what the rom-com
world and it was it was i learned a huge
amount i was i was tested a huge amount
because i wasn't
used to improvising on set as much as
all the lovely canadians it was like
this
amazing roller coaster ride of of acting
like a sponge and trying to soak up
all of their amazing choices and and and
kind of go with it whilst playing this
straighter
sort of version of this character in a
film full of people making wonderful
choices yeah um what do you like about
this story in terms of the message it
gets across
about heartbreak
i think it's i think it's a lovely
message i think i'm just trying to i i
i think it promotes a really great
message about individuality
about not relying on the other person in
your relationship
but being a part of one another's worlds
and adding
and also providing great differences and
seeing
that lucy and nick are so strong as
individuals before they find each other
ultimately at the end of the film
i think is what i really like yeah well
the emmy nominations are coming up in
the next couple of weeks
how exciting would it be for you to have
stranger things be recognized
again i i mean fingers crossed do you
know what i mean
i think it's such an interesting time
and it would it would provide some
really nice encouragement going forward
in all of our careers to be recognized
in a period of lock down
um so yeah my fingers and toes are
crossed
for everyone on the show and uh and it
would be great and uh
yeah i'm very excited to see what
happens yeah
are you excited to you know being able
to put out a movie
a lot of people are struggling right now
and you're able to put out this movie
that's not only
fun but you know just has such a
positive message
yeah extremely lucky i i keep thinking
about that as well
it's like yeah that's that's
all i could want as an actor especially
in this time of uncertainty a standard
film coming out
you